this could be interesting too
this one's more i think fits in
discovers a terrible secret about their
own family
does the movie start with character or
plot
i think it can start with either or
i like a movie that starts with
character
because plot can be
mundane
plot can
lack
originality or conceit where character
can there's still a chance for a
character to be original for a character
to be something you've never seen before
where a plot or a storyline is there's
only seven of them or eight you can
argue with shakespeare how many there
are but there are only so many
opportunities for a specific plot or
turn within each of the storylines if
you think about it so if not you're
combining those elements to create
something new where within a character
there's still an opportunity especially
if as a as a woman or as a black male we
have a chance we still have a lot of
characteristics where we've seen things
they've never seen before
ring white male you got do you have a
few less
but there's always that opportunity so
that's why i like character starting
because it's more opportunity to find
something original in that
okay so character it is i know you said
you could really be either or but we'll
go with character so we're hoping to
play like a little game and we're going
to need your help that's okay here we go
um so since you chose character we're
going to have you pick i guess five
cards and after you've picked the five
cards
go ahead and read them aloud
so maybe it's almost like a tarot thing
where they'll call to you in some sense
[Laughter]
and
this is from the wonderful game pitch
storm
they're not a sponsor or anything but we
just thought it was a cool
cool idea
it's a pretty genius little game there
great
okay and then uh
go ahead and uh if you would do us the
honor and please uh all right
interior kitchen a small mouse with a
big heart
okay okay
exterior the garden and aging butler
reminiscing about their glory days
interior top secret facility the world's
first sentient ai
interior arcade a video game character
come to life
interior at the club a lifelong bachelor
okay
so
what do i get to pick one of these
which one do you think would make uh the
best movie
um
for me at this point
it would be
i would be most interested in an aging
butler reminiscing about their glory
days really why why that one because i'm
a real big fan of merchant ivory and i
haven't seen a lot of american style
virgin ivory so i see an opportunity as
a producer to make something we haven't
seen before that has a you know and has
a predisposed audience it's there
um and if we could make it in that way
like the butler or some of those other
things i think it would be something
that could still speak to an audience
and on a smaller scale as well
like it could still just be a very
small scale movie and speak to a large
group of people
it could be set in in like the kitchen
or someplace or
the the pantry where he's continually
sort of going back to regroup for the
day or something
or it could or it could be that he's you
know
has a grand kid like i think the classic
he's got the grandkid and he's trying to
justify his life to him almost like on
some level because he's like well you
were just a servant you just served
people it's like well no i was more than
that i was actually a butler and a
butler actually has something that has a
lot more meaning than it used to have
and even explaining that so
there could be opportunities for that i
just
i don't know i just think about
reminiscing about their glory days
because their glory days are going to be
other people's days
in some level because what glory days so
butler has the butler is living through
except for maybe the children maybe his
real glories are his children are the
births of his things are his you know
the small things in life so that he's
showing it's like in contrast like yes i
was a butler like at the white house or
i was a butler for you know the kennedys
or the roosevelts and they were having
all these highs but my greatest
victories were you being born or you
going to school or you whatever it was
um so it could be a lot of things
i like it yeah it's just a niche i just
find it more
internal more of a feeling type movie
rather than these other ones which i i
could see
opportunities worlds first in india
there's plenty of that there's plenty of
opportunity for that and i'm very
interested in it
uh you know video game character i've
had some friends do that already a
lifelong bachelor interested that's
actually probably too close to home
uh a small mouse with a with a big heart
well you know i you know that one
it's a disney movie which is fine i love
disney movies but i think that this is
the one that i'm most qualified to make
if that makes any sense at all
sometimes it's about what speaks to you
that way i guess too
that's true
of the other four which do you think
would make a bad movie i know you said
all of them you would consider but which
which calls to you the least
well a small mouse with a big heart
doesn't really say very much
um it just has so many opportunities to
go in so many different
directions um that it could be anything
um so you're you know this like where
when i look at the description exterior
the garden and aging butler reminiscing
about their glory days there's very i
mean yes there's some wiggle room but
there's not a lot of wigging room
interior kitchen a small mouse with a
big heart
that could be a superhero mouse saving
other mouses i don't know
it could be a lot of different stuff
going on
but
not all of it necessarily great not
almost bad i mean it could be a very
good
mickey mouse movie right
mickey mouse is a small mouse with a big
heart right
sure okay
or tom and jerry
jerry he's just so i mean i i guess
that's one it's just vague to me like i
just see wiggle room like i could spend
hours just going oh is it this is that
small mouse could be a small mouse on an
alien plane it could be a small big
mouse i mean
with a big head i don't know anyway i'll
start making stuff up just because
that's the type of person i am
sure it sounds like too with the butler
there's more room for a character arc
if they're if they're reminiscent of a
journey yeah there's a there's a there's
an actual touch point for the character
and i like that
that's probably what attracts me more uh
it's like there's a beginning a middle
and an end already there established on
some level all you have to do is kind of
decide where you want to
drop into that
great all right so we'll go with the the
butler idea now we have a stack of the
plot cards and we're hoping you can
choose three
and then we're going to make it very
interesting from there we're going to
try to weave together a story
all right well there's
take that one and i'll take one off the
bottom too how about that and the reason
we're only doing three is because you
said character call to you more so
uh plot
not as much
get your reaction to it
tries to escape an island full of hungry
dinosaurs okay well no
that might be interesting though
if he had some very extreme interesting
adventures and it was a common it was an
extreme
comedy uh then it could have that
opportunity to that if you just like
really would start making up stuff like
big fish style
then you know because you get sometimes
maybe the kid's too bored and he just
starts making up stuff or going forward
and he's like come on grandpa you're
making it up so you may have that anyway
or he works for a wealthy family that
owns an island
exactly and they would and they would
tell him so he wouldn't want to go on
vacation that there were dinosaurs and
he believed him at one point or maybe
they just had some mechanical ones they
got from the other island who knows
right he was cleaning the cabana and
then he sees a dinosaur yeah
he's got dinosaurs dinosaur maybe it's
just you know yeah maybe it's a real
mechanic maybe it's just a guy drives
around like james bond like in dr no and
has the monster on the island that has a
red leaves of fire you know we could
have that too keep them off the island
there's many possibilities with that one
yeah there's many possibilities okay i
don't know if that one's still all right
here we go number two
this is why here we go travels through
time to save the world
okay interesting okay once again if we
go extreme on this particular character
and on the story line like if we make
him almost a walter midi-ish butler who
perhaps dreams or is like a cohort like
at times where he was like he is like
the
sidekick
of this person is being dragged along on
these things kind of like some of the
famous characters in butlering history
okay like albert and you know
ryan albert's batman's guy right and uh
who else is that we can make some up oh
they got
john favreau's character and an iron man
okay right there he's a driver but you
know he kind of gets in he's got you
know kind of tough so you know you could
have this kind of sidekick
thing where he could have had adventures
with certain maybe people that he worked
through at certain times perhaps when he
was younger or older where he was
employed and
had to perform
at higher levels of butlery
right and maybe he was the brain when
the other person got the credit as
he was a secret butler baby
okay so there we go so maybe i don't
know once again a little extreme but
here we go last one
this could be interesting too
this one's more i think fits in
discovers a terrible secret about their
own family
oh
okay much more merchant irish much more
kind of like
a little darker a little more you know
especially if we throw these two and
around it
then that'll be a dark twisting movie
it's like yes he tries to escape an
island full of hungry dinosaurs
discovers a terrible secret on his own
family and travels through time to save
the world
that's a real butler adventure boy
so
what do you like about that idea the
secret about the family sounds like
that's the favorite here maybe
uh because it has once again i think it
opens up the opportunity to
discover something that may not have
been there before and can take you in a
completely different direction now it's
just the butler being the butler
is just
more
context per se or a setting not
necessarily what the theme of the story
is
anything you don't like about that idea
well i mean
no not yet because it's like it's going
to that once again until you get
specific you're not really locked down
so until you pick one
that's when you're going to start to get
into what it's really going to push you
in one direction or another right now
it's it's pretty open
but there's a lot of terrible secrets
you can have
yeah i think so yeah what what genre
would this be
definitely i may be able to if we if we
if it wasn't a movie or maybe if it was
a movie
you know i
comedy drama a dark comedy
um or a dramedy if it was a tv series
because i could see it also being some
kind of odd weird tv series
especially if you went backwards and did
a bbc thing
uh
i don't know um or as a tv or as a tv
show or as a movie i think it would just
be interesting to just make it as kind
of as
an actor who will bring
some level of comedy to it
or humor to it
that maybe wouldn't normally
do that kind of part
you know like maybe jim carrey on his
way out
you know so it also has a chance for
really good interesting casting
it could be like you know it's like
almost like a
what's that peter sellers movie that was
his um
being there
so there's also the opportunity for
something like that and performance-wise
if you change those types of things i
don't know why i thought of that because
that's a very quiet performance but this
could be one too if he's reminiscing he
kind of just tells the story but the
character and the present is not really
talking that much and you kind of just
go through it i don't know anyway
and real quickly how would he find out
this family secret how do you envision
this butler
well i guess he's telling the story of
it and he's finds out and perhaps he
it's through
you know a journal or a diary or a
family secret through the fact of the
generations of
them serving maybe the same family
you know that's always a good way to do
it and that maybe then creates his
getting up and moving is because of
discovering that then maybe he's like
actually
related to
the the family yeah but he's a bastard
so
you know or whatever it is so
something like that